but first the British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson says he disagrees with the
ruling by the Supreme Court that's the
country's highest court that his
decision to suspend Parliament was
unlawful but he says that he's promising
to respect that verdict as British
politicians go back to Westminster with
the October 31st brexit deadline looming
there a growing demands for the prime
minister to resign he says though he'll
fight on obviously this is a verdict
that we will respect and we respect the
judicial process I have to say I
strongly disagree with what the justices
have found I don't think that it's right
but we will go ahead and of course the
parlament will come back I do think
there's a good case for getting on with
a Queen's speech anyway and we'll do
that I think the most important things
we get on and deliver brexit on October
the 31st and there's clearly a the
claimants in this case are determined to
try to to frustrate that and to stop
that I think it'd be very unfortunate if
Parliament made that objective which
were the people want delivered more
difficult but we'll we'll get on well
let's get a sense of exactly what was
said in that Supreme Court hearing this
Court has already concluded that the
Prime Minister's advice to Her Majesty
was unlawful void and have no effect
this means that the order in Council to
which it led was also unlawful void and
of no effect and should be quashed the
prorogation was also void and of no
effect Parliament has not been probed
this is the unanimous judgment of all
eleven justices right we've got Nadine
Barber our correspondent in Brighton
that's in the South of England where the
opposition Labour Party is holding its
party its conference was between in a
bit first so let's go to Rory challenge
he's outside the houses of parliament in
central London and Rory's so with that
Supreme Court ruling the unanimous
ruling
it's basically handing the ball back
into the court of Parliament
yes and Parliament's as we know now in a
statement from John Bercow Speaker of
the House of Commons is going to be
convening once again tomorrow at 10:30
GMT the House of Lords is also going to
be convening again tomorrow
this is quick movements after that
decision from the Supreme Court Boris
Johnson as you just heard earlier in the
program a short while ago basically
pretending as if this doesn't really
change anything this is the prime
minister who famously compared himself
to the Incredible Hulk it wasn't looking
particularly green or angry in his
statement to the press just a short
while ago but he was saying that he will
continue as he puts it repeatedly to get
this thing done get brexit Danny says it
doesn't change anything we will still be
leaving the European Union on October
the 31st the reporter asked him well you
can't do that without a deal because
Parliament has expressly forbid that
unless Parliament votes that that is
permissible which it has not done and is
not likely to do so
the UK is still in this quandary we have
had this momentous decision handed down
by the UK Supreme Court Boris Johnson is
still trying to push ahead with getting
a Queen's speech through that word he
said he says include another progression
of a parliament presumably a very short
one but we are heading towards an
election if he's not resigning and the
opposition parties don't want to hold an
election until after the 31st of October
when they've headed off a No Deal brexit
then the only option that they have is
to call a no-confidence vote motion in
the government and try and bring Boris
Johnson down that way that's complicated
for them though because they will have
to decide who is going to head up a
caretaker government most of them don't
want your
be-caw been the leader of the Labour
opposition party to do so so that is a
difficult thing for them to try and
reach a consensus on and what Parliament
does with the time between now and the
31st of October it is very unclear there
is gonna be a lot of talk going on and
as we see stand from this moment no
clear way out of the impasse
alright rory outside parliament in
london thank you